تخصصت رئاسه العامه لشؤون المسجد الحرام
25 موظفا يعملون على قياس مدى رضا
المعتمرين على الخدمات المقدمه لهم ويتم
اخذ اراء المعتمرين من خلال 75 لوحه
الكترونيه تمكن الزائرين من ابداء رايهم
حول الخدمات المقدمه لهم في المسجد الحرام
معي من الحرم المكي الشريف مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلمي مجددا سلطان اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد المشهد من عندك وابرز ما لفتك اليوم
سلطان
اهلا بك واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه العربيه
لازلنا ننقل لكم تفاصيل اليوم الجمعه وهو
ثاني ايام رمضان الذي يشهد اعداد كبيره من
قبل المعتمرين والمصلين هنا في الحرم
المكي لاداء الصلوات وكذلك اداء مناسك
العمره تعمل الرئاسه العامه على عدد كبير
من الخدمات التي تقدمها للمعتمرين المصلين
طوال الشهر رمضان من ضمنها وحده قياس رضا
الزائرين والمعتمرين والمصلين في الحرم
المكي اذا خصصت فرق تعمل على اخذ او قياس
رضا المستفيدين يتحدثون عن المعتمرين
والمصلين وكذلك الزوار نتحدث على اكثر من
25 موظف ينتشرون داخل ارجاع المسجد الحرام
وساحات المسجد كذلك لقياس رضا الزائرين من
خلال طرح عدد من الاسئله التي عن طريق
الاستبيان لمعرفه كم الوقت التي قطعه
المعتمل لاداء مناسك العمره او حتى الوقت
للوصول الى صحن حتى الادوار العلويه كذلك
هذا السؤال هم عن مستوى الخدمات المقدمه
بمختلف اشكال التي تحدثنا عن اعمال
النظافه او حتى التسهيلات او السلالم
وكافه الامور التشغيليه في الحرم يتم
اخذها بعين الاعتبار ورصدها الى الجهات
المعنيه تحديدا رئاسه شؤون الحرمين اذا
كان هنالك اي ملاحظات يتم التعامل معها
فورا خلال فرق رص تعمل بشكل ذكي من خلال
75 جهاز اللوح يتم اخذ معلومات ايضا نتحدث
على مشاهد نشاهدها من الملفت ان نشاهد وسط
مئات الالاف من الزوار والمعتمرين
والمصلين نشاهد اعمال سلطان بالنسبه الى
موضوع قياس مدى رضا الزوار سلطان هل لاحظت
ان المعتمرين يشاركون بقوه في الاستبيانات
استبيانات قياس ماذا رضا الزوار ام لا
البعض منهم يفضل عدم المشاركه
لا بالفعل قياس الرضا لا يتجاوز الخمسه
وعشرين الثانيه من وقت المعتمر او حتى وقت
المصلي من خلال الاجابه عبر خمسه اسئله
سريعه تم تدريب الشباب الذي يعمل على اخذ
القياسات الرضا شباب سعوديين تم تدريبه
ومتاهيلهم للتاكد من اخذ الاجوبه السليمه
والصحيحه وكذلك عدم تاخير المعتمر والمصلي
من اداء المناسك او حتى الصلوات وذاك
المشاهد اجهزه ذكيه تم الاجابه على
الاسئله بشكل مباشر وفوري ومن ثم الرفع
بها بشكل معنيه هذه الوحده هي مهمه جدا
لقياس متوسط الوقت المستقطع لاداء المناسك
والصلوات كذلك المسارات التي خصصتها رئاسه
شؤون الحرمين كيف يشاهدها المعتمرين
المصلين لذلك كل ملاحظات السلبيه او حتى
الايجابيه منها يتم الاخذ بها من قبل
الجهات الماليه وتحديدا رئاسه شون الحرمين
كل هذه الانظمه والخدمات هي للتسهيل على
المعتمر والمصلي والزائر للمسجد الحرام
نعم يعني وانت تتحدث نشاهد واياك هذه
المشاهد من الحرم المكي الشريف الاف
المعتمرين والالسنه والافئده تلهج بالدعاء
والصلاه في هذه الاوقات سلطان يعني لا
يفوتني ان اسالك كيف تتم عمليه ضبط
المخالفين لاجراءات العمره وهل تم تسجيل
اي مخالفين
اريد ان اؤكد على بعض النقاط او
المرتكازات المهمه هنالك
اجتماعات عده وتنظيمات مشتركه بين رئاسه
شؤون الحرمين ووزاره الحج والعمره وكذلك
القطاعات الامنيه في العامله الان لما
ياتي المعتمر من خارج العاصمه المقدسه يمر
عبر نقاط فرز رئيسيه يتم التاكد من وجود
التصريح العمري الخاص انه في نفس اليوم لا
يوجد هنالك مشكله ان ياتي قبل موعد العمره
بثلاث اربع ساعات ينصح به القطاعات
الامنيه بذلك حتى يكون هناك تكدسات لكن لا
يملك تصريح لا يستطيع الدخول الى حرم
المكي لانه هنالك محطات نقل رئيسيه تقوم
بالتاكد من عمليات التصاريح ومن ثم نقل
المعتمر او المصلي الى الحرم المكي في ظرف
لا يتجاوز 16 دقيقه هنالك خمسه محطات
رئيسيه يعني على سبيل المثال ان قادم من
جده سوف يمر بنقطه الشميسي ومن ثم نقطه
الفرس في الزائده سوف اريهم التصاريح
العمره ومن ثم اصل محطات النقل الخمس
المنتشره حول
بجوار الحرم المكي حين هاريهم التصريح ومن
ثم استطيع ركوب هذه الباص او الحافله
والوصول الى الحرم المكي بعد التاكد عبر
ثلاثه مراحل من وجود التصاريح حتى نضمن
عمليات عدم التكدس او عدم استخدامات او
ازدحامات داخل الحرم المكينه اهالي مكه من
يرغب بالقدوم الى الحرم المكي ايضا كذلك
يستقل الحافلات التي خصصتها القطاعات
الامنيه والقطاعات الخدميه العامله في
الحرم المكي وكذلك العاصمه المقدسه نعم